alors je vais vous
et comment
j'ai trouvé la confiance
pour oser réaliser mes rêves d'enfant
à leur dos que je suis né à morteau
comme il vient de le dire dans le haut
doubs en 1951 mais ce fait j'ai un bail
et
d'une famille plutôt bourgeoise un
milieu bourgeois alors vous voyez cette
photo de mon enfance quand je regarde
les yeux de cette petite fille ou si
vous regardez les yeux de vos enfants
on voit dans ses yeux là tout ce qu'on
est au plus profond on voit tout nous
rêve et puis on voit tous les possibles
et quand j'étais enfant voit ce que
j'aimais c'était est ce que j'aimais
puisque j'aurais voulu vivre toute ma
vie c'était lire c'était écrire des
histoires dans un cahier les inventer
s'était imaginé des spectacles alors
j'ai donné dans le jardin de mes parents
aux gosses du quartier
je leur faisais payer un centime ou bien
caramel klaus j'avais déjà le sens du
commerce
mais ma mère avait décidé que je serais
institutrice
voilà c'était son rêve c'était son rêve
avorté alors on fait quoi de ses rêves
d'enfant quand on a l'impression que
pourra pas les réaliser
wisco les enfouit
quelle est la part de confiance qu'il
nous faut pour ne pas l'équité du coeur
comment oser aller les retrouver un jour
elle est réalisée
moi je me rappelle que quand on compte
en colonie de vacances ou à l'école on
me donnait un rôle
dans une pièce de théâtre je me rappelle
que j'étais heureuse et je me sentais à
ma place et quand je lisais un livret
que le livre
m'enthousiasmait je sentais que c'était
là qu'était ma place c'était là que je
voulais aller
mais j'étais programmé pour être
institutrice
mais pour rester dans l'enseignement
jusqu'à la retraite
alors comment je vais trouver cette
confiance en moi qui va me permettre de
tout lâcher de tout recommencer de tout
oser par quels chemins de traverse la
vie va m'emmener
quel chemin je vais prendre quelques
chemins la ville sommes fait reprendre
jusqu'à ce que j'arrive à
vivre ma vraie aventure donc devenir
auteure comédienne écrivain
quand on est institutrice
alors je vais y arriver et va y avoir
trois connexions importante dans ma vie
donc déjà quand je commence dans ma
première classe c'est surtout ne pas
enseigner comme les instits que j'ai eu
parce qu'elles m'ont coupé les ailes
j'ai jamais eu l'impression qu'on a mais
dès qu'on m'a aidé à épanouir ce qui
était vibrant mois ce qui était vivant
ce qu'ils voulaient s'épanouir donc
faire tout linverse c'est à dire ne
jamais comparer un enfant avec un autre
aider chaque enfant dans ses qualités
laissez ceux qui avancent bien avancé et
s'occuper de ceux qui sont en difficulté
et puis développer la curiosité
l'autonomie
le
l'envy de bien faire
l'entr'aide
la démocratie votez décider ensemble des
règles
décider ensemble
d'aidés des textos l'ipcc on va imprimer
pour le journal trouver des
correspondances vers une case vivante
comme une ruche eh bien c'est la
pédagogie freinet et célestin freinet a
imaginé cette pédagogie dans l'école
publique dans les années 1930
et donc pour être encore plus libre dans
ma dans cette pédagogie je vais choisir
une classe unique alors malheureusement
ça n'existe plus c'est une petite école
dans un village où il ya une seule
classe pour accueillir tous les enfants
de la maternelle
au cm2
donc j'ai à peu près une quinzaine
d'enfants
et je suis nommé aux ars près de morteau
est la deuxième collection c'est que
tous les parents d'élèves sont des
paysans et je connais absolument pas ce
milieu paysan
alors je vais souvent organisées des
réunions parce qu'en fait il faut que je
leur explique que je fais pas la
pédagogie qu'ils ont connue que y aura
pas de devoir obligatoire qu'il n'y a
pas de punitions qu'on discute pour
régler les problèmes ensemble
alors on fait des réunions les apports
des gâteaux aux bois la goutte
oui et on revoit la goutte
et puis et puis je les écoute
il raconte ce sont des vrais compteur et
puis je commence de noter leurs
expressions qui me font beaucoup rire
[Musique]
c'est vrai aussi fait beau un
opus est parti pour rester
ou bien vous viendrez voir nouvelle
cuisine incarcérés
ou bien robin elle ne donnera rien à
elle donnera rien à les radins et elle
est tellement à tous que quand elle
regarde la messe télévisée à la télé ils
coupent quand c'est la quête
et
puis aussi en vous savez quand on voit
ce qu'on voit depuis quand on sait ce
qu'on sait qu'on a des raisons de penser
ce qu'on pense et puis ne rien dire
donc je note mais moi je note pour faire
rire mais mes amis je pense pas encore à
ce qui va arriver par la suite et puis
je leur demande de venir dans ma classe
pour qu'ils transmettent leur savoir et
puis leur savoir faire parce que le
savoir-faire des paysans c'est ça énorme
c'est énorme au moins vingt métiers dans
leurs mains
et et alors ils vont me donner leur
confiance
parce qu'en fait les enfants et voit
tellement heureux à l'école ils vont
tellement être emballés par les projets
qui vont mener chacun de leur côté ou en
groupes qui vont ramener du travail à la
maison et là c'est là que ces parents là
je les mets dans ma poche parce que d'un
coup ils se sont dit waouh qu'est ce qui
se passe dans cette classe que ce qui se
passe avec cette personne
et c'est pour ça que je dis toujours que
la madeleine proust est née de la
pédagogie freinet
alors la troisième collection ça va être
ma rencontre avec gérard gérard boule du
chaumont il est artiste il entend mes
rêves elle lui aussi me fait confiance
et m'entraîne au conservatoire d'art
dramatique de besançon alors là j'ai 28
ans et tout va se réveiller en moi allez
sur les planches écrire ça bouillonne et
je veux tout de suite créé un personnage
mais je veux jouer seul parce que je
pense que 28 ans il ya déjà beaucoup
d'années de frustration
inconsciente je veux jouer seul je vais
être seul dans la lumière alors je me
trouvais un personnage fort émoi la la
la la comédienne que j'ai vu qui m'a
impressionné c'est zouk c'était une
suisse tout habillés en noir qu'avait
fait beaucoup d'asiles psychiatriques
qu'avait des personnages comme ça que
nous on qui entrait en profondeur en
nous
donc j'essaye
bourgeoise bon c'est un peu le milieu
dans lequel j'ai été élevé donc ça
m'intéressait pas trop une prolos
j'essaye une clocharde une folle et puis
tout d'un coup j'ai le flash ils sont
devant moi quoi c'est c'est un trésor
que la vie m'a mis là le milieu paysan
ils sont là je les vois aux réunions
leur accent le rex leur expression leur
talent de conteur
ils vont être le terreau ils vont être
la patte de ma création je rentre et je
lis à gérard ça y est ça y est mais j'ai
trouvé je vais faire une paysanne de 76
ans avec l'accent à il me dit ben c'est
c'est ça mais oui c'est ça alors il faut
l'appeler madeleine proust
donc j'en parle aux paysans aux parents
d'élèves ils me disent oh là là mais
nous intéresse personne vous savez
c'était dans les années 80 deux c'est
vrai il y avait une ruban de mépris dans
les médias
on entendait rarement des témoignages de
paysans et même moi je leur dis bah six
mois vous m'intéressez et donc comme on
l'appelle madeleine proust il va falloir
aller chercher toutes ces petites
madeleines de proust et il faudra
qu'elle ravive la mémoire qu'elle
réveille le coeur de chacun dans chacun
un être cher
il faudra qu est que
quelques l'aï puisée dans les racines de
chaque spectateur
et puis aussi grâce aux cinq sens depuis
l'odeur de la soupe consentira jusqu au
son des cloches de vache qu'on entendra
dans la salle
mais alors comment oser tout lâcher
comment quitter la sécurité de l'emploi
une bonne retraite assurée un qui me
ferait dire plus tard comme avait d'une
grand mère d'élève obama depuis que
j'étais mise en retrait d'irène affaire
j'arrive pas à faire ce que j'ai à faire
alors comment oser comment installer
cette confiance en moi on a en 82 g 30 g
32 ans
alors je vais déjà travailler travailler
travailler
je vais me lancer à corps perdu dans un
travail de linguistique d'ethnologie et
de sociologie un travail d' écoute sans
relâche je vais interviewer une
cinquantaine de femmes je vais prendre
des notes et pendant tout ce travail
j'ai pas le temps de penser à la peur ou
à l'échec mais je vais prendre de la
distance avec les gens négatifs vous
savez ce qui nous décourage et je
comprends en fait que ma décision de
tout lâcher
réveillant eux leur incapacité à oser
donc le révèle la peur qui veulent nous
transmettre donc il faut vite sont
éloignés faut solidifier parce que la
peur c'est le pire ennemi de la
confiance
d'ailleurs voit bien les gens de pouvoir
les gens du gouvernement qui l'ont bien
compris comment avec la peur ils vont
faire de nous des moutons ils vont nous
paralyser nous ligoté donc il faut
vraiment faire tout ce travail là pour
fermer ces écoutes il
rester reliés à là où on veut aller
faire ce spectacle
donc il faut que je mette des fondations
c'est à dire que tous les gens que je
vais rencontrer des amis la famille les
gens dans les magasins a même des
connaissances vu des gens que je connais
pratiquement pas je vais dire tous les
jours je vais faire un spectacle vous
viendrez me voir dans le magasin de mes
parents qui vendent des chaussures à
tout le monde j'en parle à tout le monde
comme ça ça m'oblige à imposer cette
idée et à ne plus
cette fois-ci aux et la lâcher
alors quand on arrive en 82 je vais
réserver la petite salle de morteau 200
places
et je me dis il ya eu mille personnes
qui sont venues voir les compagnons de
la chanson
donc à mille personnes qui sortent donc
la réserve dix fois bon ça c'est mon
côté un peu bélier peut-être qui va bien
me servir
et donc
alors ça y est donc j'ai posé ma
décision j'ai affirmé je les consolider
je ne peux plus reculer je travaille je
m'immerge dans ce milieu paysan je
travaille le corps de la madeleine je
travaille sa façon de se déplacer le
court en avant tout cette position
quel âge j'observe jeunes aux jo je vais
faire un décor une cuisine hyper
réaliste puisque je ferai la souple café
et
je m'aperçois finalement quand je suis à
fond comme ça dans mon travail je
m'aperçois que quand contourner dans
l'instant présent
au délibéré de la peur
et donc quand on a libéré de la peur
c'est qu'on est vraiment dans l'instant
présent on est dans une énergie qui
vibre autour de nous et on la reçoit
cette énergie donc on reçoit de
l'inspiration on reçoit des idées
et donc je bon premier spectacle se
passe dans une cuisine comme je voulais
10 est donc bon ben on connaît le succès
qui s'est passé pendant ces trente ans
le deuxième spectacle
ça a été une ferme de sept mètres de
haut avec les quatre saisons avec des
poules sur la scène et puis le spectacle
du tour du monde que j'ai créée à la
maison du peuple à belfort avec des très
beaux tableaux dont le fameux tableau la
madeleine et en patins à roulettes
devant le lion de belfort
pour ce qu'ils ont vu
et un dé à des compliments comme un fait
tout au début à morteau
quelqu'un qui est venu me dire c'est
mieux qu'un acteur
et ça voulait dire que j'avais tellement
incarner ce personnage qu'on ne voyait
pas un acteur qui jouait mais qu'on
voyait vraiment une madeleine quelqu'un
qu'on connaissait
ça a été
vraiment
ça m'a beaucoup touché quoi ça un peu
résumé tout ce qui s'était passé
donc pendant 30 ans je vais jouer sur
toutes les scènes de france pendant des
années à paris dans des grands théâtres
et puis je vais et puis quand je ne
tourne pas j'écris j'ai publié deux
romans et puis m'arrive un cadeau il ya
un éditeur qui me demande d' inventer
une vie à mon personnage de lui écrire
sa vie et là
c'est tellement extraordinaire
cette madeleine que je connais quand
même bien que j'ai imaginé que j'ai
inventé pour laquelle j'ai j'ai déjà
trouvé des points d'achoppement de sa
vie là je vais entrer dans son enfance
dans ses premières fois et voilà qu'au
bout de trois cents pages je m'aperçois
qu'elle n'a que 8 ans
alors j'appelle l'éditeur en lui disant
écoutez je pense qu'il faudra faire
plusieurs volumes
et là je viens de terminer le tome 3
voyez ça a mis dix ans des tonnes de 500
pages en fait mon but c'est de battre
marcel proust avec ses 2000 pages de la
recherche du temps perdu voilà
donc en 2018 je fais mes adieux à la
scène pour me consacrer à l'écriture il
est grand temps comme dirait la
madeleine 1 c'est vrai que j'ai quand
même 80 ans dans dix ans voyez mais que
j'aurais jamais cru que j'allais devient
ici jeunes
voilà moi je pense vraiment que
on est sur terre
pour apprendre à élargir notre
conscience pour vivre dans l'instant
présent
pour apprendre à faire la paix en nous
autour de nous et puis de transmettre
c'est notre mission c'est ce qui se
passe ici
alors n'oubliez pas d'être heureux avec
vous même et voilà douze minutes chrono
j'ai dépassé et bien comme dirait la
madeleine proust le futur est passé on
s'en est même pas rendu compte
merci